going crazy or are water movies kind of
having a big moment right now Avatar 2
Black Panther 2 Aquaman 2 and of course
the Disney Live Action remake of The
Little Mermaid coming up soon with all
these ocean movies and theaters it's no
wonder everyone in Hollywood's been so
salty lately
[Music]
hello Internet welcome to film Theory
the show that has gadgets and gizmos of
Plenty who's it's and what's its Galore
but my favorite doodad has gotta be the
Subscribe button well it's that time
again loyal theorists That Wonderful
Time of the Year where our corporate
overlords over at the Walt Disney
Company decide to take one of their
beloved classic animated films suck all
the joy out of it and then produce a
lifeless live-action remake that somehow
manages to make a billion dollars that's
right today we're talking about The
Little Mermaid which hits theaters later
this month and uh let me just say I'm
not hopeful I knew this one was gonna be
fighting an uphill battle the second the
trailer showcased the song Part of Your
World as this big Power ballad moment
for Ariel just riffing on higher and
higher notes that's not what that moment
is guys it's not a vocal showcase it's
supposed to be a sad and reflective song
Ariel is literally yearning for a
different life now let me be clear this
isn't Hallie Bailey's fault it's an
issue of direction of missing the point
of the original story and
characterization of the song but who
knows maybe I'll be surprised to say I'm
not holding my breath as I prepare to
dive under the sea that said one thing
one thing that denies that trailers for
this movie have gotten me thinking if
this is meant to be a live action remake
well you know there's there's just no
such thing as a live-action mermaid and
while I certainly like the designs that
they did what would a realistic mermaid
look like the whole half human half fish
thing like how would that even work
biologically could that even work
biologically could a creature like Ariel
actually be real or would she end up
looking more like a Cryptid Creepypasta
and before you call out that piece of
common knowledge that mermaids would
just look like manatees because old-time
Sailors mistook manatees for mermaids
yeah turns out that wasn't a widespread
thing in fact as far as my research
showed it only ever happened once and
the guy that couldn't tell a dugong from
a Bathing Beauty was everyone's favorite
clumsy conqueror Christopher Columbus
himself yep it looks like Columbus the
same guy who mistook the Americas for
the East Indies was just as bad at
identifying aquatic mammals as he was
the continents so what would a
biologically accurate humanoid aquatic
species evolve to look like if we wanted
them to be part of our world let's just
say Prince Eric would probably want to
seriously reconsider his decision to
kiss the girl and in perhaps the
strangest Twist of all Ursula would
probably be doing Ariel the biggest
favor possible by taking away her voice
don't believe me but what more is you
looking for all you crabs let's dive in
so how does one go about figuring out
the biology of a fictional aquatic
humanoid that does not actually exist
well first off we know for a fact that
whatever we're creating it's gonna have
to be a mammal yeah for as much as I
would have loved for the answer here to
pull from some of the truly gnarly
real-life creatures that live deep
underwater just doesn't line up with the
physical characteristics that we see in
these iconic Disney designs first off
the mermaid tale Ariel and all the other
mermaids have tails that move up and
down when they swim as opposed to side
to side believe it or not this is
actually a feature that evolved
exclusively for underwater mammals
because they had limbs underneath their
bodies that eventually turned into fins
and they move up and down because that's
the way their backbones naturally Bend
see also other Aquatic mammals like
dolphins whales and seals secondly we
gotta talk about the hair Ariel and
Triton have truly luscious locks since
all mammals have hair and fish don't
clearly mermaids are gonna have to be
more mammal than fish plus the sight of
Ariel without hair is just a cursed
image that my brain cannot unsee lastly
uh this one's a bit awkward to say but
um the seashells King Triton has himself
a pair of nipples and uh one can
reasonably assume that the same is true
for all the other mermaids that live in
Atlantica that right there is a feature
exclusive to mammals that produce milk
for their young so pretty much any way
you slice it there's a lot of evidence
pointing towards our Disney mermaids
having to be mammals knowing that there
is actually a point in The evolutionary
history where this sort of Divergence
could have occurred this is known by
some researchers as the Aquatic ape
hypothesis basically it says that humans
evolve from apes that either lived close
to or in the water and that our upright
stance was born out of the need to keep
our heads above the surface this could
be where our realistic mermaids diverge
from the rest of the species during this
period of early human evolution going
under the waves instead of standing
above them that said right off the bat
there's one major problem that we have
immediately have to address Disney's
mermaids very clearly breathe both below
the water and above it this isn't a
thing that aquatic mammals are able to
do even the ones that spend a lot of
time underwater like whales instead they
have to occasionally surface to take
massive deep breaths before submerging
again for instance the longest a whale's
been recorded holding their breath is
222 minutes certainly a long time but
also a lot shorter than what we see
Ariel and the Gang doing so what would
have to be going on with our mermaids
well our real mermaids would have two
possible solutions here the first would
be to survive purely off of cutaneous
respiration basically it's just a fancy
way of saying that an animal is able to
breathe through its skin this is
actually pretty common across a lot of
species of frogs sea snakes and turtles
basically the skin is thin and moist
allowing gases Like Oxygen to pass
through and believe it or not but some
mammals including us humans are able to
respirate in the same way for us the
sort of skin breathing only accounts for
a very negligible amount of oxygen just
like one to two percent it's not nearly
enough for us to live as is but if a
mermaid needed to evolve to breathe more
through their skin yeah it's possible
honestly the biggest problem as it
applies to mermaids is that you're just
not able to get a lot of oxygen through
your skin using cutaneous respiration as
a result it tends to be reserved for
smaller animals that stay relatively
inactive so our mer people would have to
be really tiny and lazy like a frog or a
flat worm that said the second and
better solution here would be for our
mer people to evolve both lungs and
gills this is certainly rare in the
animal kingdom but it's not entirely
unheard of case in point the lungfish
lungfish are known to live in
environments that are low in oxygen like
stagnant pools swamps shallow Lakes as
such they have both lungs and gills to
help meet their oxygen needs when the
oxygen concentration in the water is low
lungfish can gulp Air at the surface and
then use their lungs to extract it when
the concentration in the water is high
though that's when they're using their
gills this sort of dual system would
help explain away exactly what we see in
the movies aerial breathing underwater
as well as on land so a realistic Disney
mermaids are definitely mammals and are
either really small and breathing
through their skin or human sized with
both lungs and gills but what would they
actually look like well to know that we
first have to figure out where they live
after all an aquatic mammal that evolves
to survive in the Caribbean is gonna
look a lot different than the one that
evolves to survive at the South Pole
thankfully we can actually figure out an
answer throughout the movie we see what
the Ecology of Atlantica looks like
their kelp forests hydrothermal vents
and most importantly coral reefs this
means that the body of water that we're
dealing with is likely warm eliminating
the North Sea near Denmark which is
usually where people assume that this
movie takes place including ourselves in
a previous Theory whoops sorry about
that we can also get Clues from the
live-action remake you see this new
movie replaces the original design of
Ariel's fish friend Flounder with this
thing gone is all the fun and Whimsy of
that original design but in its place is
scientific accuracy yay notice the five
black vertical stripes and the yellow
back that right there is the sergeant
major fish a species that lives in the
Atlantic Ocean as well as the
Mediterranean Sea in fact the
Mediterranean is definitely going to be
our best guess for Ariel's home based on
other clues that we see in the movie for
instance here in Prince Eric's bathtub
we see statues of what looked to be fish
in reality though those are meant to be
dolphins and they match the art style of
various fountains found throughout Italy
we also see flamingos appearing in the
song Kiss the Girl a tropical bird that
can appear in lagoons deltas and
estuaries around the Mediterranean I
could keep going on and looking at the
plants and animals of this region but
perhaps the strongest evidence of all
comes not from the movie itself but
rather from a video about the movie on
the official Disney princess YouTube
channel while reviewing fun facts about
the film they outright say this Ariel
grew up in the Mediterranean right yes
not to be outdone they follow it up with
this also did you know that
I mean it doesn't a much more clear cut
than that it's coming from an official
source so with that finally settled we
can actually start looking at how these
mermaids would look and why first off
some basic stuff it's almost certain
that our mermaids would have webbed
fingers on their hands this would be a
really simple adaptation that would help
our mermaids a lot allowing them to more
easily swim and navigate underwater it
won't even be that wild for this to
become prominent through natural
selection humans today are often born
with syndactyly or fingers and toes that
are fused together so it's very possible
that this sort of thing would absolutely
show up in an evolutionary offshoot of
humans our mermaids would also have eyes
obviously but those eyes would likely be
bigger and with larger pupils you see
while fish eyes and human eyes work
largely the same way focusing light onto
a retina in the back of the eye fish
eyes are usually rounder and more
flexible this allows them to quickly
adjust to changes in water pressure and
the way that water is bending the light
because fish and mermaids live
underwater they also have to deal with
lower light conditions as such having a
larger retina with a higher density of
photoreceptors is going to help their
overall sensitivity to life light we'd
also likely see their eyes having a
coating of Tears a slippery Oozy
secretion meant to protect them similar
to what dolphins use to protect their
eyes it's also likely that our myrrh
people wouldn't have any sort of human
looking ears if you look at images of
whales Dolphins walruses and seals
you'll notice that basically none of
them have ears instead they have these
two little holes in their heads that act
like ears this is because any sort of
external ear is going to create drag in
the water and slow him down thereby
getting eliminated during The
evolutionary process so at most armor
people would just have two holes in the
sides of their head speaking of drag
what about that hair arguably the most
iconic part of Ariel's whole aesthetic
is her long bright red head of hair but
would that be a thing for a real mermaid
certainly not just like ears long hair
would provide a lot of drag as our
mermaids tried to swim through the water
never wonder why Olympic swimmers wear
caps that cover up their heads one of
the big reasons is to keep their hair
down to reduce drag they also have to
shave all their body hair off and I mean
all of it for the exact same reason they
want as little drag as possible when
they swim and this tracks for most
marine mammals whales and dolphins have
a few whisker-like hairs to help them
sense their environment but otherwise
their smooth skin similarly manatees
have little tactile hairs all over their
body seals and walruses on the other
hand have both whiskers and layers of
slick fur that stick well to their skin
our mermaids are probably going to have
something similar either no hair or
slick hair that runs down all over their
body but this does bring up another
Point see mammals don't just have hair
as a means to be stylish a lot of the
time fur or hair is needed to keep these
mammals warm trapping a layer of heat
between the skin and the fur without
that hair well our mermaids are going to
start suffering if they don't have
protection from the cold according to
the Encyclopedia Britannica temperatures
in the Deep parts of the Mediterranean
tend to be about 55 degrees Fahrenheit
or 13 degrees Celsius now humans can
begin suffering hypothermia at
temperatures as high as 60 degrees
Fahrenheit or 15.6 degrees Celsius so
our mermaids are going to need some sort
of solution here otherwise they're going
to be freezing to death so again we turn
to other marine mammals to see how they
survive in these depths and the thing
that we find in common across all of
them whales Dolphins manatees seals and
walruses blubber in case you don't know
blubber is a type of fat tissue that's
just really good at insulating body heat
basically it allows animals to stay in
cold environments by keeping their body
heat inside of themselves kind of like
an internal blanket additionally it also
has the advantage of adding buoyancy
while you swim meaning that it helps
save energy while moving through the
water if an animal has blubber it
typically covers the entire body so
that's going to inform how our mermaid
looks let's just say they're not going
to have the thin figure of Ariel or the
swole chest muscles of Triton it's gonna
have to be a bit on the chunky side to
survive at the bottom of the
Mediterranean also their skin is likely
to be the color that we see on dolphins
and whales sort of light blue gray on
their stomachs and a dark blue gray on
their backs this allows it to act as a
natural camouflage against the backdrop
of the ocean so a realistic mermaid
probably not what Disney has plastered
all over posters for this movie they're
gonna be mammals with gills and lungs
they're gonna have webbed hands they're
gonna have big eyes coated with Oozy
gooey tears they're gonna have bluish
gray skin with no ears and no hair
except for a couple of whiskers and it's
all going to be wrapped up in a chunky
dad bod from layers of blubber that are
covering their whole body to keep it
warm also they'd likely evolve a more
pointed head to help them stay
hydrodynamic as they swim through the
water just looking at this thing Eric
definitely would have had to have been
very open-minded in order to fall in
love with this but there is one final
detail about our anatomically correct
mermaid that's really scary and it's
likely gonna make you never look at the
Little Mermaid the same way again
remember the whole source of conflict
within this movie comes from Ariel's
voice she loves Eric and she wants to go
to the surface to be with him but Triton
says no so Ariel strikes a bargain with
Ursula a sort of deal with the
underwater devil where Ariel gives up
her voice to be able to walk on land and
pursue her relationship with the prince
and while in the movie This creates a
central conflict in real life this
decision to give up her voice it would
have literally been the single best
thing that Ariel could have done in the
situation why well because if she had
her voice she likely would have killed
Eric let me explain you see things
aren't always better down where it's
wetter because the ocean is a loud place
like really loud might not believe bit
if you're relaxing on a boat or at the
beach but that's because underwater
sounds reflect off the surface of the
water and back down into it yeah it
might shock you because human ears
aren't evolved to hear underwater but
water is an excellent conductor of sound
so much so that sound can travel four
times faster and farther underwater than
in air plenty of sea creatures actually
use this to their advantage making
really loud sounds to communicate sea
horses can growl at a volume of 115
decibels to intimidate Predators louder
than a rock concert the toadfish
attempts to attract mate by vibrating
their swim bladders at a volume of 177
decibels louder than a shotgun blast and
the pistol shrimp can snap its claw shut
at a volume of 220 decibels louder than
a NASA rocket launch and it's not just
fish and invertebrates either the
Aquatic mammals are also really loud the
elephant seal can bark at a volume of
126 decibels bottlenose dolphins can
reach 163 decibels and blue whale calls
can cap out at 188 but that's nothing
compared to the single loudest Marine
Mammal and the loudest animal in the
entire world the sperm whale which can
produce clicking sounds up to
233 decibels now anything above 120 can
harm a human ear it only takes 165
decibels to burst your eardrum so that
233 decibel click that's already gonna
be some bad news those sperm whale
clicks have reportedly been so loud that
they can cause temporary paralysis in
parts of the human body science
journalist James Nester is even written
that the clicks could potentially quote
vibrate a human body to death if our
mermaids are reaching anything close to
that in terms of their vocal volumes at
minimum once Ariel comes above the water
just the act of speaking is gonna
physically harm Eric potentially
bursting his eardrum and permanently
rendering him death someone call Mr
Beast I think we have a patient 1001 and
if the mermaids are somehow able to get
as loud as a sperm whale well it's a
good thing that it don't take a word to
kiss the girl because Eric wouldn't be
under the sea he'd be six feet under the
ground I guess all of them should be
happy that Ursula wanted Ariel's voice
because at that point you have to wonder
who the true poor unfortunate Soul
really is but hey that's just a theory a
film Theory and cuts do you want more
Disney theories right now but why not
check out our Trilogy of videos where we
look into Disney's death count which of
Disney's classic animated films is the
most deadly trust me you're gonna be
surprised by the movie with the most
deaths you want something a bit more
recent check out the video talking about
the truly terrifying copyright laws that
surround the new Winnie the Pooh horror
remake and why this might just be
Disney's worst nightmare as always my
friends I'll see you next week